my man Mitch cocaine Mitch McConnell
himself has been asked to step down as
Senate Majority Leader or Senate
Republican leader and he says no what do
you say to those who are calling on you
to step down do you have any plans to
retire anytime soon I have no
announcements to make on that subject
what do you say to those who are I'm
going to finish my term as leader and
I'm going to finish my Senate term thank
you I'm with Mitch man that guy wields
power great I don't care how old he is I
don't see a better alternative right now
if you told me there was some great
prospective Republican leader in the
Senate waiting in the wings who's going
to be right-wing and conservative okay
great but I don't really see that so as
of now I'm sticking with my man Mr
cocaine